Candace is in Indiana and she says we
are currently behind on our house two
vehicles and credit cards along with
multiple old medical bills I know we
need to catch up on our payments before
working on our emergency fund however
I'm not sure where to start on catching
up well Candace you guys need to do a
detailed written budget where every
dollar has a name before the month
begins every month and you need to
figure out why it is that you are behind
that you have a job loss have you
replaced the job did you buy something
you shouldn't have bought you need to
sell it did you are you disorganized
most and you don't watch what you're
spending and you eat out too much well
you need to figure out what the cause is
of all this bleeding and you've got to
stop the bleeding and then you're gonna
have to work like crazy people like take
six extra jobs and that's good news
because around Christmas lots of people
are hiring so you need to be like
working like all the time all of you and
that way you won't have time to go out
to eat too because you can't afford to
go out to eat you're broke so you need
to work all the time when you're behind
on your house you're behind on your
vehicles you're behind on your credit
cards you're behind on medical bills
you're behind on utilities that you need
to work all the time now then what we do
is we prioritize what we catch up first
okay the very first thing that needs to
be current in your house is food your
family needs to eat before you do
anything else you probably have enough
money coming in to take care of that but
you need to make sure that's done before
you do anything the second thing you
need to do before you do anything else
is lights and water you need to keep the
utilities on it's cold out there you
need to be able to take a shower because
you're gonna be working a lot and you're
gonna be using that hot shower a lot cuz
you're gonna work all the time if I
mentioned you're gonna work all the time
I want to make sure you understand
you're gonna be working all the time
you're freaking broke and there's a
sure-fire there's a place you ought to
go when you're broken that's to work
that's the deal
okay so now we got food and we got
lights and water the next thing you do
keep your house so you get current on
your mortgage before you do anything
else you don't pay a dime to your
medical bills you don't pay a dime to
your credit cards you don't pay a dime
not one penny to anybody else until
you've done these things and then you
get current on your vehicles and here's
the amazing thing most people can get
all that current within 30 days food
lights water shelter and car payments if
you don't do anything else you can get
current on all that real quick I'm
saying nothing else all you're doing is
working you're paying all the money you
stopped your 401k you stopped you don't
pay anybody anything for anything you
don't spend any money on anything until
you get current on the house you get
current on the cars
you turn on the lights and water and you
got food in your house everything else
can go jump in the creek dude nothing
gets money until then you've got to get
the four walls of your house protected
so that you can live to fight another
day now if you're current on your house
and your cars and you got lights and
water and you got food you live to fight
another day now we can start worrying
about some of this other stuff like
credit cards and medical bills and we'll
get current on them and you just
prioritize those guys out the same way
you look over and start getting current
on them or start settling with them one
of the two if you're far enough behind
if you're six or eight or ten or twelve
months behind you may want to just offer
them a settlement and save up an offer a
lump sum settlement on that you got a
$2,000 medical bill you know offer them
a thousand bucks off from 500 bucks but
you got to save that money up to do to
make that offer right it's the only way
that works so that's the process food
lights and water shelter transportation
gasoline in the car and that way you can
go to work all the time because you're
gonna be working all the time and that's
how you do it this really does work it's
a formula and you need to do all of that
and get current before you even start
talking about working the baby steps or
building up an emergency fund or
worrying about a death snowball or any
of that kind of stuff you can't worry
about any that kind of stuff when
they're going to take your freaking
house and your cars away from you and
nobody gives a rip about a stupid old
medical bill and why your car
getting repo'd so you get your car
straightened out in your house
straighten out and you get food on the
table and you get the lights and water
and you never again get behind on those
things no matter what happens you can
make enough delivering pizza to keep
those things current oh and by the way
you're going to be working all the time
a pizza delivery might be what you're
doing I don't know it could be over I
don't know what you're doing you could
be working at the mall it could be
working at the Christmas tree lot yeah I
don't know what you're doing but you're
doing a bunch of it and you're not too
proud to do anything because you need
money right now that's what you do you
get after this stuff hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]